[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks so much for
being here if you did notice if you're
always listening or you're watching on
YouTube Ryan's not feeling well so Bryce
is sitting over there you can see him on
the wide shot see that Jason popped to
the Y there you go Bryce you good yeah
what's up guys yeah Bryce man he's the
pretty he does everything Bryce does it
all
it's nice to have you here dude yeah I
have a face yeah you raced up here this
morning to help me and uh here we are
glad to be here yeah we got a great pot
podcast today yeah it's uh me do the Max
Headroom thanks for listening thanks for
making this podcast
you know one of the podcasts that you
listen to and taking the time really
appreciate it we uh we love having you
here and if you you're here for Deborah
Ann Wall and you're like I don't care I
just want to hear it and you're fast
forwarding you know it's fine but if you
like the podcast make sure you subscribe
at inside of you podcast on Instagram
and Facebook at inside epod on the
Twitter we're also on YouTube uh
everywhere you get podcasts you could
listen
um write a review Apple podcast you
could write a review it really helps the
show
um also if you want to join patreon
become a patron
um go to patreon.com inside of you and
uh
patrons really save the show they really
do I talk about this every time but uh
and there's different tiers the top tier
gets their name shouted out at the end
of the episode they get packages every
four months they get YouTube lives and
blah blah blah they get a lot of great
stuff but if you just want to join and
support the podcast or donate a little
to keeping it going patreon.com inside
you also the new inside of you online
store
great merch new a Smallville scripts
autographed lunch boxes tumblers tons of
stuff take it out check it out inside of
you online store and last but not least
uh our album is out sunspin.com check
out all new merch we've got new uh
Shirts Mugs calendars t-shirts
um what else
CDs the new CD is out the music's only
available on CD right now I said mugs I
think I said mugs but you get a
monograph or whatever go to sunspin.com
you can also book a zoom with the band
book a show with the band a private show
all that stuff all right enough with
that stuff
also I'm gonna be in San Francisco the
20
uh fifth weekend a Smallville nights
with Tom Welling and the following two
weekends are Columbus and then
Pittsburgh so get your tickets get your
small nights tickets and uh this is a
great guess I love Deborah Anne wall she
talked about her being bullied you know
her from True Blood uh was really
awesome to talk to her and she opens up
and I think you're gonna really dig this
so without further Ado let's get inside
Deborah and wall it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know right before you came
here yeah uh by the way I was gonna kid
around and say right before you got here
Deb
I can be dead Are you seriously for sure
you would hate Deb no I'm okay with Deb
I don't like Debbie Debbie that's the
only one I don't like really yeah only
my grandmother Debbie could you get me
some boat huh why would she talk like
that she did not talk like that how did
you talk
um I don't know my there she grew up in
Buffalo and lived in Long Island
um yeah so my mother my both my parents
are from Buffalo New York but uh my
mother moved to Huntington my husband
grew up in Dix Hills Dix Hills we have a
lot of family on the Long Island and
then I'm from Brooklyn you're from
Brooklyn yeah before you got here I was
teaching Ryan how to do a Christopher
Walken impression okay I've been doing
it since probably 97. and a lot of
people do it the wrong way okay you know
they're usually like
hello now hello and everything so it's
pretty good no it's it's not happening
because walking's very subtle you know
he's like you're a son [ __ ] and he
is
and I was teaching him right before you
came
and I think it helps can can you do
Impressions
I am not good at Impressions you don't
think you could do it Urban my thing no
just try to find like in the back of
your like throat chest go yo son your
son not bad I don't know yeah I've never
been a mimic it's never been something
I've been good you don't have a good ear
no no I do not have a good ear for that
stuff I'm not good at accents it takes
me a long time to work that stuff out
can you sing
um I have a nice sounding voice I would
not say that I'm a singer
um I'm not trained or anything like that
but I I could carry a tune you can carry
a tune yeah that's good yes
um so you've done obviously a lot of
stuff we were like True Blood Daredevil
the Defenders The Punisher series uh
your host of Dungeons and Dragons show I
mean we're gonna get into it
um I said True Blood yeah well I just
got back from doing
um from barting in San Diego this summer
so I was doing Taming of the Shrew at
the old Globe you and your theater
theater is my the thing I always really
wanted to do with my career so while
like the TV in the film has been
incredible and such a journey it felt a
little bit like a side path but the
thing I really wanted to do so being
able to go do that this summer was
really special well I have a theory yeah
tell me if I'm wrong okay some people
say no I just always wanted to be an
actor I didn't care about Fame I wanted
it because I loved being an actor and I
think it's kind of [ __ ] I think
there is always a like a little glimmer
or a little morsel of I want to be good
where I'm famous if you're good at what
you do you there's a good chance you'll
be famous see that's where I disagree
with you I disagree with you there's
there's a strong part of me yes my ego
absolutely wants people to think that
I'm good that I'm talented that I'm
artistic that I'm a deep thinker all of
those things right I want to be those
things and I want people to think of me
that way okay however
I know so many incredibly talented
people who never get recognized well I
know that on a higher level so I think I
think
wanting Fame and wanting people to think
you're good can be two different things
I just feel like if you want people to
think you're good well you want people
to think you're great I want people to
think I'm great
by getting that reciprocated yes like
the feeling is validation that I am good
I am great and I think a lot of people
need that in life yeah some people say
don't worry about what everybody else
thinks don't worry blah blah and it's
such poor [ __ ] it's impossible not to
think about what everybody thinks of you
yes now you can't obsess over it but if
you do a play you can but I mean you can
you can but I think you know when I was
doing theater in college and I was doing
plays and stuff and I realized wait a
minute I got something here the teachers
are paying attention to me other
classmates I'm getting cast as a lead
role people are there's things going on
and like hey but that feels good it
feels good and it's like maybe this is
my key to getting famous well with that
but I think that's because I I can
genuinely say for me maybe because I'm a
bit introverted or a bit nervous around
people the the idea of being known is a
little bit
fraught
Define fraught
I mean scary okay on a certain level
um the idea that people would have
thoughts about me outside of my control
or outside of what I feel is real
um that they're gonna think things I
mean I I was very very badly bullied
when I was younger and so that I think
contributes to this idea of that I don't
want anyone to ever
everything anything bad about me or
anything that's so Fame comes with all
of these people that you know Fame is
just notoriety it's not good or bad
right and so all of that accolades that
come with that also come hey Deborah Ann
mole and you know a big teeth or all of
the things that people want to say about
how you look or your or your talent
she's not good she's annoying she's all
of those things so I don't know that
part I I don't I don't want the fame
part enough to take on the other half do
you read reviews no I stopped that a
very very long time ago why did you stop
because you read a bad review no because
I just know me I know that I would not
be able to handle it you'd pick it apart
I would pick it apart and I I think and
I'm definitely the kind of person who
would not remember the good stuff and
would only remember the bad stuff I
don't watch my own work I haven't done
that really years and years and years do
you know I had one interviewer One
review
say something like
I did this movie and it was actually
really funny yeah funny movie called Hit
and Run very funny movie my friend Dax
directed it yeah did a great job he was
the lead I thought he was great
um and Tom Arnold who I thought was
great and like most of the reviews were
good
and this one reviewer said
Dax Shepard isn't funny
Tom Arnold has never been funny oh and
Michael Rosenbaum will never be fun
and I go
what I just started laughing I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing wow I
mean he's got he's got it personally for
him or personally for all of us this guy
was going and wanting to hate the movie
and he didn't like us already right so
you can't pay attention to that stuff
but like I mean it was just like I saved
it I have it yeah and he will never be
funny that is amazing oh yeah you got to
save stuff like that and
um but you don't watch yourself no it
makes me defensive I don't want to be a
defensive actor I don't want to be
thinking about all the stuff that I
didn't like when I watched it before I
want to be free and let a director and
an editor and a someone elsewhere but
you got nominated for Screen Actors
Guild award for True Blood as an
ensemble you know that was for all of us
all together that's true but you have to
think if you're nominated for something
you're probably pretty damn good I gotta
say again my husband and I were just
talking about this last night I don't
know I I kind of think a word shows are
[ __ ] they are I don't watch it
it's really it's money making it's
promotion it's you know again it's all
yeah and that's not to say that if you
win one you're not good like it's a it's
a scam a lot of really wonderful actors
win a war isn't a nominee for words and
great shows or upper things but again
there's so much incredible work that
never ever gets lifted to that level and
I even look at something like True Blood
and Daredevil and while it wasn't always
the greatest there are moments where I
go [ __ ] we really found something cool
here and it will never be considered
merely because of the genre element of
it or you know it's not [ __ ] yeah so
there's certain things that that cross
over that either because of what the
material they're based on or things like
that but um it's rare
um so yeah I so at a certain point I
think to be healthy in this business you
do have to go I am satisfied if I felt
like I did great work which is why I
stopped watching because at the end of
the day
I would go home and go wow I had a real
experience I had a real moment I got to
watch my co-star do something
spectacular and we created a great
moment
from this point on I don't decide the
music I don't decide the cut I don't
decide the color correction I don't
decide any of it I just have to go home
and it goes into someone else's hands so
watching it later and going ooh I don't
like the way I sound or the way I look
or the choice that they chose there or
that the choice that I made just ruins
that wonderful day that I had where I
thought I was great okay so it's better
for me to kind of go home keeping that
confidence and the earlier work that I
did
I could feel the self-consciousness
creep in and it made me less good right
because you're like oh I don't like that
thing on my face I don't like when I
smile there's a dimple or something or
like not you I'm just saying yeah but
like you know I I that's it is I I will
I'd watch stuff and go oh you're bloated
and then that's on your mind the next
time you work yeah versus the story but
maybe you should maybe sometimes you
watch yourself and go you need to lose a
few pounds Rosenbaum you need to work
out a little more oh you want to be you
get your shirtless in a scene you better
Pump It Up hey you you know you know
you're not listening there listen more
it's almost like critiquing yourself but
also if you can do that constructively
if you can I think some people are
capable of doing that I'm not
um
and also at a certain point again I you
have to make these decisions I decided
very early on that because I know that
my ego will cause
insecurity problems for me but I just
have to go I'm letting it go I'm never
dieting for any of this stuff I'm never
going to worry about any of that I don't
know hair and makeup that is someone
else's Department I will they're going
to do their job and I'm going to trust
them you know I might have opinions
based on the story I want to tell but
I'm never I'm gonna try not to let
vanity
control my job I'm gonna pick all I'm
gonna make all of my choices
based on the story I want to tell with
this I am going to be in a documentary
and they're going to capture it
um and that is just the the only way I
have found for me to successfully do
work that I feel is good at least
this show is sponsored by better Help
Therapy online
the amazingly talented people who appear
on my podcast and me let's be honest may
seem like we have it all figured out
but we obviously don't navigating any of
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new relationship or becoming a parent
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual a trained therapist is the
next best thing therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside you is
brought to you by First Alert did you
know a fire department responds to a
fire every 23 seconds smoke and carbon
monoxide alarms help provide an early
warning in the event of a home emergency
having enough First Alert smoke and
carbon monoxide alarms is one of the
best things you can do for your home and
your family install alarms on every
level and in every bedroom of your home
now once alarms are installed it's
important to maintain them by testing
them regularly also remember alarms
don't last forever and need to be
replaced at least every 10 years they
are on duty 24 7. if you cannot remember
the last time you replaced your alarm
it's best to replace the unit completely
for a replacement option my favorite is
first alert's 10-year sealed battery
alarms 10-year sealed battery alarms are
convenient and eliminate the need for
battery replacements for a decade along
with alarms fire extinguishers are
essential make sure to place fire
extinguishers on every level and in
common spaces like the kitchen and
know-how to use them for more
information on Fire Safety Products
safety tips and educational activities
you can do at home with your family
visit
firstalert.com
fire prevention month firstalert.com
fire prevention month
I I've had conversations about acting
where it's like
you know some people are like
who cares if it's a success or not
you're doing what you love right you're
just doing what you love I go I
if I
I don't just want to do anything now I'm
very I'm lucky that I don't have to
thank God but in the beginning I would
do everything right because you're just
building confidence and doing whatever
and it doesn't matter how shitty and
Lord knows I've been on shitty [ __ ]
things shitty yeah I mean like shitty
yeah and but then you get to a point
where you're like
I want to I want to do things that
really have a chance that really are I'm
surrounded by really great people
they're they're putting everything they
can into it there's a passion I think
this could be really good yes I genuine
I'm not you know there's
and as long as I'm acting I'm having fun
but if you're on a show and it just is
not good and getting not good ratings
but staying on the air like a lot of
shows do or they do get good ratings and
you just what I'm trying to say is
don't you find it difficult if you're
really an actor and you love acting and
now you're stuck on something that's
really not great or would you do
something not great just to do it just
to act no no I mean the the joy of
acting is
um doing great material and having great
roles and being challenged in that way
so no I mean I wouldn't feel happy being
stuck on something that wasn't
challenging me however I did have a
teacher say this that I thought was
interesting
she sort of said it that
for an actor like the the the words of
the writer's job for an actor it's
everything you don't say so at the end
of the day like having a baby is having
a baby whether it's written by Tennessee
Williams or the junior writer at the new
CW Show you know like it's that's an
experience it's a human experience and
even if your lines are crap you can fill
that experience
with your own imagination and your own
whatever you bring to it and so that can
you can kind of make things challenging
now again it is more fun yeah to be
challenged by great writing and great
experiences but I have found in those
circumstances there are ways to kind of
elevate it for yourself have you ever
done something you're like
I was
I was [ __ ] great in that yeah and
then go no one cared no one paid
attention no one noticed me never got
nothing all the time
really most of the time I feel that way
really not not that most the time I feel
that it was great but most of the time
when I when I have a great day where I
feel like I've done really great work I
feel like it just slides are you
disappointed do you want to hear
something yeah yeah it would be nice and
and I think what I do is I try to live
on
like I remember when we were doing True
Blood and speaking with some of my other
actor friends and talking about
insecurities and some of them were at
the time like IMDb still had message
boards and people would go on and read
all of these lonely angry people who
would just say terrible things about you
online and they would go and read it and
I remember sitting down with one of them
once and being like okay you know weird
guy on the internet and Alan [ __ ]
ball who keeps bringing you back and
keeps giving you challenging material
and keeps saying that you're the [ __ ]
right like at a certain point that has
to matter more his validation of you has
to matter more than this person's and so
you know what I tend to thrive on like
you know we did an episode on Daredevil
um that focused on my character Karen
Page we did a whole back story we took
they they I will forever be indebted to
Eric Olson for championing this to the
writers who the writer who wrote it he
took the entire crew upstate New York in
the snow and did this amazing
stand-alone story about her past and he
collaborated with me on the story and we
you know I felt involved and creatively
fulfilled by it I was one of the best
weeks of my life in my career wow I am
so [ __ ] proud of that episode I still
haven't seen it to this day what they
did with it in the end but the
experience that I had and and working
with everyone
it I'll never forget it
he wrote me and said lovely things
did anyone ever mention that episode to
me outside in the public anything like
that no no one no one
um but I that has to be okay right it
has to be okay okay that I'm crazy proud
that Charlie was proud of me that John
was proud of me that Vincent was proud
of me that that Eric Olson was proud of
me that you know that my husband my
family that these people you know were
proud and that has to be enough and what
you think it's like when is enough
what's enough man
ultimately you know that we get to a
point where like we have to have the
confidence and
wherewithal to sort of just say
I'm good yeah I know what I'm doing I'm
proud of myself moving on I don't need
any external validation when I've gotten
better at because because external
validation is a thing that I struggle
with I've gotten better you know when I
have those thoughts where I'm like God
damn it why couldn't that have been I go
you know what silly Deb you know what a
what a silly thought you know like this
is this person who did all this for you
he wrote this he set this side of time
he set this budget a time you know
budget aside all of this you know to do
this and that is such a huge
um vote of confidence
um that he he he did that for me so I
you know I I try to hold on to that I
have a little whenever someone sends me
a nice email I put a little a little so
I think I even call it like confidence
long or something like that and whenever
I'm having a moment I'll go read it and
it's that's smart yeah it's generally a
lot of stuff from from people whose
names you might not recognize but
they're very meaningful to me I like
that yeah you know we did a movie
together we did what movie did we do
together one scene with Forest Whitaker
and Malinois I had one scene with Forest
Whitaker and that was it so we didn't
work together yeah but I was in catch 45
You're Gonna Catch 44. sure hot
Louisiana summer uh yeah interesting
interesting movie yeah interesting
little movie why didn't we get Oscar
nomination I don't know I don't know I
asked myself that all the damn time
um tell me about because you you briefly
just kind of mentioned it and I saw some
interview with you it wasn't even an
interview it was more like you talking
to people about being bullied and kind
of showing support yeah and saying hey
you're not alone yeah
take me back when did The Bullying start
it was mostly Middle School
those really great foundational years
when you're trying to figure out who you
are and everything that happens affects
who you become for the rest of your life
11 12. yeah yeah right in there
um what was it what were they picking on
you about
do you even know well I mean that's the
that's the big question right and I
think I I spent a lot of time trying to
figure that out because
if it was something
real then how do you grapple with that
and go God I'm just actually an
unlikable person who doesn't deserve to
have friends
or
you go all right
maybe everyone is scared and hurt and
freaked out at this point in their lives
and there's a mob mentality and I was an
easy target you know I'm I was and
probably always will be the kind of
person who's going to cry before they
fight back
um and you know that seems to mean like
a less scary Target
um
so yeah I think I think I was an easy
target I think you know I was
why were you an easy target because I
didn't fight back because that's because
you didn't fight back I would just
crumble
um you'd cry in front of people yeah
um and I think also you know I was very
young I wanted to be a kid I mean look I
became an actor I play make-believe for
my my life right like I enjoy I play d d
i play board games these are my favorite
things to do there's a there's a part of
me that very much loves that childlike
part of my life
um
so I think I wanted to sing and dance in
the hallways I loved learning you know I
was that kid who was like yo teach you
forgot to give us homework because I
really wanted to read more of the book
you know so that was the antithesis I'm
sure that you were you probably would
have hated me no I wouldn't have hated
you I just would have known you because
you're really smart well I'm not it
wasn't even smart you know I was not a
straight A student I wasn't even the kid
who like loved school I just really
liked learning and and particularly in a
certain number of subjects and
unfortunately my favorite subjects are
everybody's least favorite subjects I
love math and science so I was the kid
who really wanted to excel at math
um and so yeah I think I think there
were things like that that made me
probably a little bit annoying to other
kids which is no excuse
um and then I was an easy target
[Music]
um
so it's interesting I I've
thought a lot back to it because it's
like a weird experience of being
invisible and totally conspicuous at the
same time like being absolutely like
everyone is ignoring you
everyone and pretending that you either
don't exist or are an annoyance to them
and
and yet they are
so aware of you they're they're so aware
that they are choosing to pretend that
you either don't exist or aren't there
or go out of their way to make you feel
less than do you ever
to this day
sometimes get lost in thoughts of the
past and remember that little girl who
was picked on and does it cause you to
be emotional or do you have you kind of
I tried my husband I tried to watch that
Bo Burnham movie eighth grade I got
about 20 minutes into it and just like
fell into like ancient heaving Psalms
that
I couldn't I don't think I could act
um because they were so deep you know
and and to get on with your life you do
a lot of things to sort of save yourself
and
um I'm still to this day trying to get
over the coping mechanisms that I used
um
so you know yeah we we stopped that
movie I don't know I don't know if I'll
ever be able to finish it but I I kind
of know it's the greatest movie ever
made because it were there do you
remember names do you remember certain
girls or boys you like you could riff
them off you just rip you know go you
because I could do that too because I
was picked on a little bit too and I was
the shortest kid in my high school and
um
but I could remember names I can
remember names I could say names right
now I'm not gonna say because they're so
specific it's very specific you know
it's like if I said Raleigh Johnson
he didn't pick on me though but I also
like it was also like I said it was a
mop it was everyone and so there's
there's that but there's also just this
kind of like
cloud of energy in a way that I remember
more than anything
um
because it was you know it was a smaller
school and so everybody kind of got on
the same page I remember my mom saying
something she was like oh he's always so
proud of you you always made friends
with the new girl
and I was like oh that's because you
don't know that she was the only person
who would talk to me because she didn't
know yet and about two weeks after that
she would no longer I remember that
happened when I was
I was a sophomore and there was a new
Fresh couple freshmen that came in and
I I knew these guys were going to be
popular yeah they were like good looking
guys and they were like you know
athletes and I remember becoming sort of
friends with them
and hanging out with them and remember
it was for like a couple of weeks until
they caught on that I'm I'm not popular
I'm not I'm not what you thought and it
was like crazy how much that matters
when you're that age did you get did
things change when you went to high
school so yes I ended up my coping
mechanism at first was just to shut up I
just stopped talking I stopped I just
was the invisible person that they would
have preferred me to be
um I mean I spoke in class and I spoke
at home but I just I just didn't try to
be social with anyone any longer
um and then honestly I started doing the
plays and that was the only place that I
talked
um how did you get I guess since you
loved dancing in the hallways and all
that this I had always loved theater and
things like that so I was like all right
let's give this a shot
I always dance
I'm singing and things like that so I I
did that I did a couple of plays and
something in there around eighth grade I
did Guys and Dolls Junior and I remember
like walking into the cafeteria and
seeing the like place that I normally
went and sat alone and then seeing the
place where all the kids that I had done
the show with were sitting and I
remember like very distinctly taking
that
a deep breath and deciding to go sit
with them
um and that kind of shifted things and I
I still
it took me years and years
and probably I'm still not done figuring
out how to just like let myself be me
right
um because that still feels like such a
a dangerous thing to do
since that's what got me you know
humiliated so often
inside of you is brought to you by Geico
Geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance well of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to Great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life Geico can
help like with insurance for your car
truck motorcycle boat and RV even help
with homeowners condo or renters
coverage you could save even more with a
special discount when you bundle your
coverages plus add the easy to use Geico
mobile app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to Geico becomes an Easy Choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save inside of you is
brought to you by patreon My Level
patrons go to patreon.com inside of you
it truly helps the podcast past top
tiers get things like packages sent to
them every few months Notes From Me
YouTube lives questions with me and the
list goes on please support the podcast
we couldn't do this without you
patreon.com inside of you
I know how you feel I really know what
it's like to
I've talked about it about becoming an
actor because of that like I didn't have
I've said it how many times have I said
so I didn't have to be me yeah and then
I got lost somewhere along the way
between who I really was and who I
thought I was yeah and then all of a
sudden you get older
and you realize
I don't know exactly who I am I'm right
I should know who I am by now and it's
just because you're so used to I'm a
little ashamed of who I Who I Am
um and it does it has felt like so much
of that Journey has been trying to get
back to being that pre-12 year old kid
um who I look back and I'm like wow she
was so free and she was so excited about
everything and and gosh I I just let
those
stupid 13 year olds like Define me for
the rest of my life and there are
decisions I make today that I'm like God
damn it I'm still making choices based
on these kids
um yeah it's so nuts to me and I so you
mentioned the d d thing which I I came
to late in life
but I did I made the show relics and
Rarities that again I'm ridiculously
proud of and that's on now it's it's
just it's not airing now we it's on
YouTube you can find it I'm doing a
weekly show right now you can watch
called uh children of Verte but this was
a thing that we did a while ago that
actually had a budget it looks fantastic
we have great guests on it again I'm so
proud of it
and after that it is
it is probably 12 year old Deb
to a t all of the things that I loved
the enthusiasm the you know childlike
innocence to it all kind of exists
within that show and so it was a really
scary thing to kind of put that out
there but it was as we said when you
talk about recognition validation it was
accepted not just
you know in a small way people really
went wow this was wonderful and it meant
so much to me and hearing Matt that kind
I didn't know I needed that kind of
validation that 12 year old Deb needed
that kind of validation wow
um so that that was that was more
meaningful than I thought it was going
to be that's crazy I thought we were
just gonna make a DND show and then
afterwards I was like wow I needed to
hear that people like
12 year old Deb wow that's you know it's
so it's so I mean it's growing up is so
hard to a lot of people out there it's
just like finding your place who am I
where do I belong who are my people what
do I want to do what's my purpose these
are things that continue on in life
folks they continue on I'm 50 and I
still have questions a lot of questions
I don't know when I'm gonna have them
all answered probably not till I die and
even then I probably won't but
you'll find your people yeah you know
you'll find
folks that make you feel like you can be
you yeah like I've been re-watching
Modern Family I shouldn't say
re-watching I'm first time watching
Modern Family it's just been a fun thing
to to go through and he said the Jesse
Tyler Ferguson says a a line to the
young kid who's struggling and he says
you know I know it's it's hard to be
different now
but you'll see when you're older the
thing that makes you different is the
thing that will make you special and
make you you know exceptional yeah and
it's it's just hard at that time in life
when we're becoming self-aware I mean
quite literally I think all of us could
have a story right around 12 13 of
something that was foundational to who
we are and I think it's because we start
to realize that people see us and think
about us and we become self-conscious
and isn't it amazing how
there's always if you if you think about
your past and Ryan you probably have
some thoughts to this but throughout
your lifetime
it takes what we all need is someone to
Believe in Us
hopefully it's more than one right then
you're that's good but there's always
even now like there's a casting director
who believe in you one person who kept
calling you in because they saw
something there's that teacher who
didn't think you were a dummy who took
the time because you had add and taught
you something there's you know you know
maybe it's your mother or your father or
whoever it is but you need we all need
somebody besides ourselves to believe in
us to give us that confidence and
um
you know I could I can name there's a
handful of people in my whole life yeah
that just I remember going
he took the time with me yeah
I was this rambunctious little kid I
couldn't focus my grades weren't good I
was colorblind I didn't even know it
till I was 14. and somebody said hey
let's let's sit down let's work this out
well I always think of that list and I
go that should be your Oscar list right
like everybody talks about the speech
that they practice and they're going to
thank their agents and the director and
the other actors and make sure
but the people who actually really got
you there are those right they're the
people who took the time and and took
the patience not just the people who
were doing their job next to you yeah
and maybe just maybe
I'm probably not the first person to say
this but maybe it's all the people who
didn't believe in you that gave you the
courage and the strength to actually
prove them wrong so maybe thank you oh
you [ __ ] out there who didn't think
anything of me or are you yes I think
people to varying degrees are are
motivated by that I'm not terribly
motivated by that I won't discount it
entirely but I don't have a lot of like
I'll show you in me really not really
you don't go to work and when I'm gonna
out act this [ __ ] scene
not for the 13 year olds I thought I
mean I in a playful way sometimes I feel
that way and it might be to like psych
myself like I had to see with hadu I got
to do a scene with Vincent D'Onofrio oh
I did too it got cut from a film it was
a great scene it's a great scene I'm
sure because he's amazing he's so
amazing yeah how was it it was wonderful
it's again one of those moments where
I'm like I am so proud of this I do not
ever want to ruin the way I feel about
this moment um but you know but going in
it could be very intimidating again
knowing myself I was like I could very
easily become self-conscious and do a
terrible job because I can't let go of
that so I walked in that day going I'm
I'm gonna blow Vince's Navi out of the
[ __ ] water that's gonna be my job
today is to just like act circles around
him and you know that's that's an
overstatement that got me to parallel
hopefully you know that is awesome
that's a great if you could really
believe that and feel it there's such a
a good energy yeah that you could just
enjoy because a lot of the times
we're all self-conscious we're nervous
you know we want to know our lines so
good that we don't nothing can FaZe us
um we don't want to be tired we want to
have you know there's all these
variables that could I didn't sleep or I
can affect your performance I didn't I
drank last night I I you know I I just I
have indigestion my stomach's bother
there's and you have to perform yeah no
one gives a [ __ ] no pun intended you
have to do it yeah and you have to be on
and this is going to be recorded and and
be there for life when you see this when
someone they could play this moment and
that's how you have it's a lot of
pressure do you get nervous still acting
do you go on set and you're like oh my
God I'm I'm nervous I'm nervous every
day yes I mean I get comfortable but yes
I I mean yes some nerves I I do think
I Rebrand them a little bit as
butterflies like that it's nervous
excitement
um
I because I have that ego that wants me
to be great and wants to be considered
great even if it's just by the people in
this room rather than the World At Large
but again I know that that actually is
gonna do the opposite you know letting
that voice in too much is actually going
to make me less good
um so yeah so sometimes I think it is a
it's it's putting on that false bravado
that Swagger a little bit to sort of
trick yourself into feeling that way uh
which is you know what actors do what do
you do what do you do sometimes get a
little punch to your hand come on you
got the ships what would be my thing you
know Jesse Eisenberg I remember I was
doing in a movie wasn't a very good
movie and I love Wes Craven but I just
did I did the movie Just because of
course it's called cursed and I just did
this part and he wrote me a letter and I
was like oh man I didn't read the script
I just want to work with you and I
watched Jesse Eisenberg and for every
take you just jump up and down every
take and turn around in circles but
right before I take yeah and and I have
my own thing yeah and everybody has
their own thing I know that Leonardo
DiCaprio at least he used to
um he used to be just running around set
acting like an idiot just talking to
everybody action and he'd just jump into
it and I like doing that if I think
about this unless I have a ton right
right but if I I don't want to focus too
much because I think I'll stress out too
much and I'll be comfortable for too
long so I try to get out of my head so
right so that's it right it's to get out
of your head it's to be present in this
actual literal moment not some fake
moment in your mind where you did you
did it a certain way right that's the
goal so honestly for me it's like
okay sorry then that's the show folks no
you want some more water or is it good
that's foreign
so it's a little bit of there are
bottles in a wine rack over there yeah
there's light on the wall over there
I can hear the air conditioning humming
up above
oh there he's sitting over there oh wow
he's a really nice smile I like the way
his hair kind of flips that way you know
and it's it's putting myself in this
literal moment
with the literal things around me I I'm
not a big fourth wall person I think for
me rather than doing a lot of work to
make cameras disappear I just accept
them they're just here it's just there
it's just another eye in the room right
I'm just more concerned with you and and
what I need to communicate to you and
and oh what did what did your face just
do there you know like so for me it's
I'm a big homework person I am always
going to be an overachiever and an
overworker I do a lot I get better the
more work that I do the more fire I have
underneath
um but once you're there on the day it
is about trusting that that's there and
just going wow he looks cute today or oh
I'm so [ __ ] mad at him look at the
way his nose upturns that might want to
punch that nose in the [ __ ] face you
know like a punch it you know it's it's
finding the little things right here in
this moment right now that put you kind
of where you need to be for the scene at
least that's what works for me no that's
amazing have you ever been intimidated
by an actor
I mean he said dinofrio but you didn't
seem intimidated by him no I talked
myself out of it it's so scary in that
role though he's great I know how you
did it
so scary well he's supposed to be scary
but also Karen is supposed to be
Reckless right I mean in that role I'm
I'm meant to kind of like I don't get in
trouble because trouble is drawn to me
it's because I go looking for it because
I'm like I'm gonna ask the right [ __ ]
questions and that's dangerous so you
know so again the character can give you
some Swagger you know knowing knowing
that that's the attitude that comes with
it
um you know he's also not that scary
like right before that scene he asked me
if I liked his suit you know like he was
insecure about her he was you know like
oh look it's the white you know so you
know you have to remember these other
things are happening you know as it's
going on
um
I've ever been intimidated I get more
intimidated by again the social period
outside of the acting well they like me
as a person
and also think that I'm good uh once
action is called I don't know I have a
pretty good I have a pretty good Pavlov
Instinct from action to cut of of
feeling a lot Freer
I've always said this I've always been
kind of jealous of people who have
strong religion in their lives I have
never really had that because there is
this idea that like you're on a path and
someone is looking out for you and
what's meant to be is meant to be and
there's like this safety net that you
whether it's predestination or anything
like that that you can't really make a
wrong choice because it's already been
made whereas I'm out here going if I
make the wrong choice I may never have
the career I want I may not meet the
people I may not have the family I might
not have the security you know these
things so I'm constantly terrified in my
real life of taking a wrong step I'm not
much of a risk taker in my real life
but storytelling
it doesn't matter in scene three if I
cry if I yell at you if I spill water on
the floor you know you might be really
mad at me about the water on the floor
right now but if I do it in the scene it
doesn't change the fact that we have
that that doesn't change scene 40. Scene
40 still happens
so there's so much more freedom to be
brave and to make choices that are scary
because I can't change
the outcome
so for me that feels like
a safety net and I so yeah action to cut
feels like the safest place in the world
feel our lines pretty quickly yeah I
have a pretty good Instinct for that
um and I like these so that you know I
people always talk about like oh how do
you memorize all those lines I just just
did Shakespeare and it's a lot of lines
and people are always impressed that you
can memorize Shakespeare but I always
say you know it's not really
memorization it's learning by heart
right I mean it's you learn lines the
way or at least I feel like you should
learn lines the way you know the words
to your favorite song they're just sort
of in you
um and the great thing about acting is
generally someone gives you a cue they
you know they have a line before yours
which sort of tells you what your line
is supposed to be yeah have you ever had
lines given to you the day of a ton of
lines not much no I haven't had would
you freak out I would freak out that
would be a little hard for me there's
also those sets certain writers that
want you to be absolutely word perfect
I again that's not the right environment
for me they would not like me as an
actor I I have to believe in my heart
that writers and actors want the same
thing which is an authentic living
breathed experience in a moment and if
that means that I have to go uh at some
point during your life
all the time then that then I think that
that's an acceptable you know sort of
compromise there and and most of the
writers that I've worked with haven't
had any problem with that and and even
with small I'm not a big like hey can we
change this line unless it's something
really important I've done that you know
I can count the times I've done that in
my career just little ad-libs but little
ad-libs are you know if if uh what or uh
goes to uh I don't know they're usually
fine with little yeah I would hope so oh
yeah don't say uh
why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
um how intense is John Bernthal
Punisher he's a kid I met him once and
he was really sweet but he's got this
intensity and all his role that I'm just
like
I remember he
told me a story he was working with
Sylvester Stallone yeah
and Sylvester said he was boxing and
Sylvester Stallone came in and bought
like took his something it was his rosin
or rosin I don't know what it was but
it's something you don't do and he goes
hey what are you doing he's still
honestly what it would
and he says you know better than anybody
that you don't take that from another
boxers like you know you're absolutely
right I'm sorry about that you put it
back down and it got a little intense
but like he told me some great stories
but he's uh about meeting Robert De Niro
yeah anyone did he ever tell you that
stuff no he didn't tell me you wanted to
meet Robert Jr after they worked
together uh-huh and at the end he goes
look I waited the whole time I just want
to say well De Niro goes
why don't you let's come the trail I
have to have a drink whatever I don't do
dinero only comes in the trailer and
um Bernthal kind of says I love the
story he says you know De Niro's
thinking they're just gonna have a drink
and two guys hanging out right and burnt
I was like I just gotta say this you're
my idol man I mean I I you're he's yeah
you don't have to do this and you can
tell De Niro's really uncomfortable he's
like no no I wanted to I want to say
this I guess it's on this so you know
you don't need to do this it's like no I
have to say this he's like okay
and he just went on about how much he
loved him and how it meant to him
working with him and how he's acting and
I go so then he loved it right he goes
no it was the most uncomfortable awkward
[ __ ] thing that ever happened in my
life yeah but but is he intense
um yeah I mean certainly he can be you
know um but I generally especially with
me I would say I can only speak from our
relationship he was supportive he was
Lifted Me Up he always talked about how
excited he was to work with me how much
he wanted me to cross over and do the
work with him on Punisher we would still
love to work together on other things in
the future you know so I I have a lot of
love and respect for John so he he's
great he's a great actor great actor
great
um and you know and and I always said
John's John's failing is actually how
great of an actor he is or not his
failing but his you know his Achilles
heel maybe is that because you know
we'll read a script and you know most
actors we go oh yeah this is good you
get really excited about the thing and
sometimes that blinds you a little bit
to some of the logic of the scene
because you can just like suspension of
disbelief just skate right by it not
John
John will read something and he'll be
like okay he's good so but why why would
I give her the gun you know and you're
like oh why why would he you know and
suddenly you're like oh yeah that
doesn't make any sense why are we doing
and then suddenly you've got an hour on
set where you're trying to figure out
what you're gonna do instead kind of
thing kind of because John is too good
at what he does wow yeah if you had to
choose between True Blood Daredevil or
The Punisher
to do again oh to do again
I'm gonna guess yeah good Ryan you're
gonna guess too
I'm gonna say it was True Blood you're
wrong
huh I was gonna say that too yeah I I
would I would say I would say no
um partially because the the Marvel
series feel unfinished to me because we
got canceled when we thought we were
gonna have more
so there is a part of me that was like I
had more to say about Karen and and we I
felt like I was in the middle of that
story whereas True Blood you know again
for all of its ups and downs and and
triumphs and flaws we did get to wrap it
up I knew that we were wrapping it up I
could say goodbye to everyone I stole
something from the set you know I didn't
get to steal anything from our our
Daredevil set and I didn't get to say
goodbye to the crew because we all
thought you thought we were coming back
um so that's really what I I would want
back and I wouldn't have all of that
back obviously
um and The Punisher and Daredevil feel
kind of a one to me mostly because
the character really
lives and thrives in Daredevil but I
loved the work I got to do in Punisher
and also you know I played a 17 year old
um True Blood and you know that show was
like a soap opera you've grown up a
little bit yeah and I there I really
enjoy it as Karen playing someone my own
yeah because that is at his point I was
like even you know even if three years
have passed over the seven years of True
Blood I am now a you know a 28 27 year
old woman playing a 20 year old and
having to keep alive a little bit of
that like innocence and and insecurity
everyone else is older and stronger and
wiser and you know that stuff and so to
go be Karen and be kind of like I've
lived and I've seen some [ __ ] and
own that a little more I think I as
Deborah needed to play someone more like
that after having been a kid for so long
if you had to choose between never doing
theater again or never doing film again
oh I I'd never do film again and you
just act on stage that's how much you
love so much fun it's so much fun
it does not pay very well but it is so
much fun
um
yeah it's an easy answer for me and
that's not to say I haven't loved the
film and TV work I have it just doesn't
thrill me what about if you had to
choose knowing you're not going to make
any money in theater
you're going to make enough to just live
oh that's okay if I could live that's
okay okay
um you know I mean even right now I mean
look I I haven't had like a good paying
steady film or TV acting job in a while
right what do you mean so I'm in the
world a few years
that's enough and I was on either and I
I you know I was on cable which is you
know a good payday but it's not Network
payday you know you can't live the rest
of your life off of a good run on a
cable show
um you know you have a family you have a
mortgage you have you know and I'm smart
with my money but still like you have to
retire at some point these are all
things you might have to send a kid to
college at a certain point those are
very very real
um obligations and and so you know I'm
I'm in the stage right now where I have
you know like four side jobs really
part-time jobs that kind of what do you
mean part-time jobs I mean they feel
like full-time jobs because it's a lot
of work what are they so I have a
podcast
I want to be a guest you well uh if you
were you on True Blood I was never on
True Blood so unfortunately I don't know
that we can have you in if you were a
Super Fan maybe we could bring you in as
a second okay but uh yeah we're doing a
podcast called truest blood um Kristen
Bauer who is Pam on the series
totally have her on Christian's
incredible Storyteller she's hilarious
guys listen to this podcast it sounds
like you should if you like True Blood
truest blood truest blood so we we
basically go through each of the
episodes and not only do we talk about
our favorite moments but we do serious
behind the scenes so how did we get that
special effect done we do that on our
show talk about Tom and I do Smallville
I love it yeah yeah that's great so
really behind the scenesy stuff it's you
know if you know me and I'm an
overachiever I I deep dive Research into
all this stuff so it's really fun
um so we're working on our second season
of that right really soon
um I'm writing a Dungeons and Dragons
campaign book that will be published in
2024. have you ever played with Vince
Vaughn I have not played with Vince
Vaughn played with Joe Manganiello Kyle
Newman I played with Kyle for sure yeah
definitely love Kyle I've never played I
played it when I was a kid twice or
three times but it takes a while to
learn how to play doesn't it it does I'm
a big believer though for new players
that you shouldn't worry about the rules
especially with this fifth Edition the
fifth edition is really intuitive and if
you have a good DM that can just tell
you what to roll you should play from
your imagination so I I generally with
new players don't don't tell them well
invite me I'd love to try it come you
should totally come and play especially
I have all this material I need to play
test so I just don't make fun of me I
don't get angry with me be patient
remember I talked about the teachers
patient yes patient is very good
um and and yeah and then I have this
weekly d d game that I'm running once a
week uh that's a completely different
story
um so yeah and you make money for these
I make money for these get out yeah I
love that a lot of good things you know
I know I read about and you talk about
it because you support it but your
husband has a disease called yeah
corrodareemia
we say yes uh uh hard hard to pronounce
even harder to cure is our our little
tag right right and um how's he doing
he's doing good EJ EJ is his name yeah
so he's quarter Remy it's an eye disease
um that essentially erodes sight from
the out outside in so he's lost his
peripheral vision and any you know over
time he'll lose all of it how when did
this start it's lifelong it's genetic so
I started from birth from birth he
didn't always know when he was growing
up he did he didn't always know about it
you know I think that's also some of the
the trouble with it is that you know he
was maybe labeled as clumsy or you know
uh not observant or things like that
when it was an actual condition oh
that's gotta suck not no one's new
person I mean oh
um and you know and it because it's
genetic there's family issues that come
into that and and are you passing this
along and what is your legacy and all of
those things and uh you know I think so
for EJ he's done a lot of work over the
years he's run marathons had comedy uh
benefits and things like that he's very
into the Improv World
um that you know so we've tried to raise
awareness and money to sell sort of help
uh find a a cure or treatment because
where can they go to so um cure chm.org
is a place where you can donate uh the
foundation fighting blindness we love
them they're fantastic so those are
places that you can go
um yeah and how old is he uh my
husband's in mid-40s and I mean what do
they give a Time expectancy of like hey
it can change for a lot of different
people uh some of it is protection the
more he protects his eyes from the Sun
the longer his vision can maintain but
now you know he's got central vision as
if you were looking through straws very
tight central vision so that's tough
yeah so it's is there certain glasses or
something that could help with that not
at this time no
um it's also you know RP is a very
similar condition but from what I
understand and I'm I'm not a scientist
um with RP it just shuts the
photoreceptors down so potentially
there's a world in which they could turn
them back on with certain treatments
unfortunately with court aremia those
cells are destroyed so there is no
turning back the clock at this point
right other than stem cell therapy which
is we're very behind in that technology
of course
um so you know we're looking more at a
treatment that could potentially halt
the degeneration at this point is that a
struggle every day is it sort of like
for him really just having to you know
being frustrated probably and all this
[ __ ] so it's like you know that's
something you have to deal with yeah you
know yeah it's a big deal and and I
think for him too you know he like you
loves
things that represent you know movies
and comic memories memories you know
he's a big collector and Savor of things
and he loves you know he takes a lot of
pictures and video whereas I can't be
bothered to do any of that so you know
he has a Fortress of Solitude that he
keeps you know it's filled to the brim
with statues and books and comic books
and posters and things like that and you
know I walk in there and I have anxiety
but for him it's this soothing wonderful
space of love and joy and you know so
much of that enjoyment comes from the
visual and being able to see these
things and watch these television shows
that he loves but you know accessibility
is a huge thing you know we are huge
fans and love it when the different
networks start having audio descriptive
uh tracks with their TV shows that's
very helpful going to ball games and
there's certain you know yeah you know
even easier going to the movie theater
sometimes they have headsets that'll do
the audio description but even then like
a lot of times they're not working so
it's this big fight to say like hey you
would be making the day of so many
people if you just had your headsets
ready to go and in functioning order
right like that's a struggle when just
trying to go see a movie you know
um
yeah and you know I think there's a lot
of fear and
um loss surrounding it but he's a pretty
exceptional person and that he's really
directed that energy into you know
um trying to fight the good fight that's
awesome yeah well donate again yeah
donate ffb the foundation fighting
blindness or qchm.org all right [ __ ]
talking with Deborah and well by the way
if someone has to sing a song to you
with your Nate last name in it what song
is it I mean you had to have been saying
a song like like for me Rosenbaum people
would say you dropped a rose and bomb on
me baby
all we are is just uh Nah The Brick in
the Wall I have never heard that before
really no as I said I I have only heard
my name spoken in taunts
um so yeah so yeah I don't it's on the
first in the song yay
I will take this moment home with me
[ __ ] talking with Deborah Anne wall uh
these are patrons top tier patrons that
ask questions go to patreon.com uh
inside of you to become a patron and
support the podcast we need people like
you thank you and these These are the
[ __ ] talking questions Jamal F how
involved did you feel Netflix was in
shaping Daredevil are you satisfied with
how the show ended well I mean we
brushed upon this a little bit
um I mean I think Netflix was a really
great home for that show in that they
did trust most of them now I wasn't in
any of those rooms so I don't know how
intense they you know Netflix was as a
network but I love the version of the
shows that we did on Netflix and yes I
was sad that it ended without more
notice all right Sheila G favorite
experience working with Charlie Cox on
Daredevil Charlie
favorite experience
got you know
I always looked forward to the days that
I worked with Charlie one because he's a
he's a hard worker like me you know I I
don't think he's quite so far as like
hey you forgot to give us homework but
he enjoys right the work that's the
challenge he likes the challenge he
wants to rehearse he wants to talk about
the scene so I remember in the beginning
of season three you know every every
scene with him was a joy but the
beginning of season three we were going
to do a flash flashback to the scene
that just
um followed his reveal that I am
Daredevil to Karen pate
and he and I had already had a lot of
conversations about what had happened
between then and the next time that they
met so when Eric Olsen our showrunner on
season three came in
and said that he wanted to revisit that
moment
he worked very closely with us and
wanted to know what had we imagined
um you know he wrote a pass and sent it
to Charlie and I and Charlie and I read
through it and discussed it and sent
some back some thoughts and they
realized it was this really lovely
collaborative back and forth and when we
finally got there that day to shoot it
I don't know it just it it was another
one of those moments with him where I
was like I'm so grateful this is you and
not some [ __ ] who's you know too big
for his britches you know you
that's good yeah uh okay by the way I'm
glad I didn't say this before because
that was an amazing answer but this is
rapid fire oh I'm sorry but I didn't say
no I didn't say rapid fire but I'm glad
I didn't because that's an awesome story
oh God so I'm glad I didn't say rapid
fire because you might not have told
that story terrible at rapid fire right
here we go well you don't have to be
that fast okay you could just look like
10 seconds or less no whatever you want
if you want a minute go but you know
it's just quick Trilogy uh no Jeanette
any thoughts about revisiting True Blood
in a movie any updates on season two of
your podcast well we just talked about
season two is back
um I know nothing about any any movie I
love the character I mean if it was well
written sure and I kind of like I'll say
this I it True Blood did not end the way
that I thought it was going to end or
really even wanted it to end I was kind
of like she should go like explore the
world and like become queen of Louisiana
or something like that so I would love
more story for Jessica out of that
Christy I loved the show True blog what
would the crew like to work with on True
Blood exceptional so I'll say this
it we worked nights it was freezing cold
in Greer Ranch where we shot this show I
mean we're talking below 30 like below
20 some nights and we're out there in
little dresses you know for Louisiana
nights kind of thing uh it was cold it
was long we shot routinely 16 18 hour
days our crew did not have to come and
be there for all seven seasons and we
had a crazy retention rate and that's
because of how professional they were
how good they were also HBO compensating
for that kind of commitment uh well
they're exceptional I mean doing the
podcast now and getting to talk with a
lot of them again and remember what a
special experience that was that's
amazing Dana asks will we see you in any
of this upcoming phase of Marvel movies
and Disney series
I can say this they have not called me
yet
so as of now
um I am not a part of it
um I would be thrilled to get to be a
part of it they know where I am yeah
um like I said I I love the character
Karen Page I love telling that story I
feel like I have more to say but it is
up to them what kind of story that they
they want to tell Charlie Cox was in
Spider-Man I mean it's there well
they've already announced they're doing
a daredevil series that's happening
um I they just have not contacted me
about it maybe they will maybe they will
that's why I'm saying yet so I have not
contacted me about it Raj and we sort of
dabbled on this we actually talked about
this did you have any family or friends
that weren't supportive of your decision
no we didn't talk about this wrong
support of your Pursuit the decision to
pursue an acting career
um some extended family
you know True Blood is not for everyone
and it is racy and there were a couple
of people who I think
like the line I can remember is uh oh
well we're so happy for you but you know
I'll
someday you'll do work we can do be
proud of basically is what was said to
me
um but you know that's that's people
have lots of feelings about what
television should be and and all of that
and so I I'm very proud of True Blood I
think that it tackled you know for all
of the soap opera and the blood and the
gore and the genre of it I think it
really tackled some really interesting
ideas and asked people to challenge
their thoughts so
I'm proud of it I love it well you're
doing so much I mean you really are
doing a lot do you have to keep busy to
to sort of function or do you can you
can you take a break oh I can take a
break you can do nothing I can do
nothing I can watch Modern Family for
hours if I need to
um I I can't because I have things to do
um because I do have to you know care
for my family and and do those things
awesome yeah well this has been a real
this is fun thank you thank you so much
for uh allowing me to be inside of you
today that's what we say in the show
okay perverted
um and uh this has been awesome so thank
you thanks
[Music]
she was a sweet a sweet lady sweet woman
very talented and um I just I always
like when we do in persons it's just I
feel like I think you feel an energy
like a back and forth yeah I mean the
zooms are fine but I always like having
someone in the room yeah and she had a
nice energy opened up a ton she opened
up a ton and she was very calming you
know I like when people calm me when I
feel like I could just talk to them nice
so that was really nice uh if you didn't
listen to the intro it's got all the
information for the cons that I'm doing
and the handles and the uh our website
uh inside the online store patreon all
that stuff you might want to listen to
it to join to help support the podcast
and a bunch of other fun stuff and the
new album sunspin.com go there to get
merch and the new CD and right now I'm
going to do shout outs
here we go
these are shout outs these are top tier
patrons who have given to the show and a
lot of these names man
freaking they've been here I just did
boxes yesterday with my friend Joey put
boxes together and I always make those
little notes
um
but it's just amazing it's amazing how
some people have been here over three
years loyal loyal just supporting the
pockets after a while I don't know what
to say anymore I'm just like oh my gosh
you're still here sometimes I say that
I'm like you're still here you're still
supporting this podcast I guess it means
something to you
um and it means a lot to me here we go
Nancy D Elia s Sarah V little Lisa you
Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie amaraj C Joshua D
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Kimberly e Mike E Eldon Supremo 99 more
I'm gonna change my glasses so I can
actually see some of these names I do
this every time
I bet you guys that should be a contest
what name will I get to before I switch
my glasses it was far
yeah and it started to blur Santiago M
Chad W Leanne P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
blind and Chris H Dave H Sheila G Brad d
Ray H tab of the T Tom and Liliana a
Talia M bet CD Chad L Dan and big Stevie
W Angel M ran and C Cory k-dev Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C gavinator David C
John B Brandy D Camille s Joey M Eugene
and Leah Nikki G Corey Patricia Heather
L Jake B Megan T Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Sarah s Eric H
Shane r m r Andrew M zotuichi 77 Oracle
Karina n Amanda R Amanda s gen B Kevin e
Stephanie K Lena 82 jorel and Billy s
I've said it a million times I could not
do it without you
um thanks for listening to the podcast
thanks for being here and supporting
hopefully you'll have a great holidays
it's coming up Thanksgiving we got
Christmas we've got great guests coming
up so you don't want to miss it nice
over the holidays just [ __ ] sit [ __ ] you
could [ __ ] sit in a nice room maybe [ __ ]
in a nice room and listen to the podcast
listen all these fabulous guests that
are coming up and of course a reminder
to listen to talk Ville which is every
Wednesday that's tomorrow Tom and I uh
dissect uh every episode of Smallville
and uh thanks for all your support there
and uh we love you from myself Michael
Roswell I'm in the Hollywood Hills
and I'm Ryan tears I'm Ryan that's Bryce
I'm Bryce in the Hollywood Hills yes
okay we'll see you later thanks so much
for being here and most importantly
be good to yourselves I will see you
next week
[Music]